even in the context of a series that
regularly receives criticism for feeling
formulaic pokemon brilliant diamond and
shining pearl are particularly familiar
as remakes of the 4th gen titles diamond
and pearl these are homages to an era of
pokemon when the series was just
starting to settle into a comfortable
niche not only that but these are
extremely faithful remakes right down to
the visual style and classic combat
mechanics that makes the experience feel
downright homey if not a little deja vu
inducing even those who haven't spent
the last few decades repeatedly catching
them all know the gist by now you're a
plucky kid who goes on a grand
cross-country adventure training pocket
monsters and ultimately becoming world
champion it's recognizable in the same
way that you basically already know that
mario is going to have to save the
princess and has a certain level of
simplistic appeal
[Music]
that same brand of simplicity is present
in the mechanical underpinnings diamond
and pearl hailed from a simpler era of
pokemon before full 3d became the norm
instead they hearkened back to the
series roots as an overhead sprite based
rpg there would be a clear delineation
between a grass tile and a town tile and
you would move from one to the other as
if on a checkerboard you can see some of
these roots at work and the brilliant
diamond and shining pearl remakes too
while your character has full range of
movement in the world and the geometry
isn't terribly blocky there are some
obvious anachronisms how npcs always
move at right angles for example or how
floor tiles are sized to fit your
character perfectly it's only mildly
distracting and for the most part it's
just charming
[Music]
equally charming is the art style itself
especially in the overworld while the
more recent sword and shield have
adopted a more lithe elongated style
that looks similar to the various
pokemon animated series brilliant
diamond and shining pearl have
translated the squat pixel art of the
originals into an equally squat and
adorable animated chibi style your
character looks appropriately retro
while simply exploring the tall grass or
walking around town but the style looks
especially great when the camera zooms
in closer during dialogue sequences at
those points the artwork really shines
because you get to see the contours and
vibrancy of the characters they look
almost like living vinyl dolls
[Music]
similarly many of the pokemon themselves
benefit from this new art style
especially the designs that are more
elegant and simple like the pleasantly
plump starly some of the more complex
designs suffer for it though since the
flourishes can look a little awkward
that's a problem when you're going to be
spending a significant amount of time
looking at monferno's red outline butt
but otherwise isn't too distracting your
own characters and npcs also change from
their squat chibi forms into more sword
and shield like models during battles
and those look perfectly fine even if
they have a little less personality on
top of the visual distinctions these
remakes pack some quality of life tweaks
from their later games that make it
easier to go back to this generation
borrowing a page from sword and shield
exp share is on by default and
distributes experience across all
pokemon currently in your party which
makes grinding out levels much less of a
chore likewise acquiring hidden moves
provides you with permanent access to
them regardless of who's in your party
which will automatically take care of
navigation tasks like breaking rocks or
surfing through the water without
needing to keep a dummy pokemon on hand
and you can access your pokemon boxes
from anywhere rather than needing to
head back to town to check in at a
pokemon center you can have a pokemon of
choice follow you as well once you've
progressed which adds a nice sense of
personality to your friendship with the
little pocket monsters the other major
addition is the grand underground a
revision of the original underground
mechanic that borrowed some elements
from more recent games you can see
pokemon roaming freely and some pokemon
can only be caught by exploring here
similar to the wild areas in sword and
shield this change doesn't feel massive
but it does seem primed to add longevity
to the endgame once players have fought
through all the gems and bested the
elite four for all of its adherence to
the tried and true pokemon formula
diamond and pearl and their remakes are
notable for breaking from the format
though only slightly there's
significantly more story quests that
take place between gems especially on
the back half that prolong the adventure
and help break up the pacing some
pokemon games can feel repetitive as you
simply rush from gem to gym so this is a
welcome change plus unlike most pokemon
games you'll actually wrap up the main
story revolving around a mysterious
legendary pokemon before you ever reach
the 8th gem and it will never stop being
funny that a 10 year old just walks into
a sports competition flanked by a
pokemon space-time god because of this
[Music]
[Music]
while the main adventure is mostly
smooth sailing there is a surprising
difficulty spike when you reach the
elite four and pokemon champion the
final challenge is representing the end
of the main quest this five battle
gauntlet is meant to be the most
challenging in the game but it ramps up
to such a higher degree than anything
else in the game that it can make for a
rude awakening the rest of the game also
generally keeps pace with your levels
without too much grinding especially
with the advent of the exp share but for
this final challenge you'll probably
need to spend a significant amount of
time grinding to get your party up to
snuff there's a reason this game's
champion and especially the final
pokemon has a reputation as one of the
toughest in the series
[Music]
pokemon brilliant diamond and shining
pearl keep enough classic elements to
feel like a comfy nostalgia trip while
smoothing over enough of the rough edges
that they feel relatively contemporary
with other recent pokemon games it can't
be easy for a storied franchise to pay
homage to its legacy while also
modernizing in this way but brilliant
diamond and shining pearl strike the
right balance it's the classic pokemon
you remember without most of the little
annoyances you've forgotten
[Music]
you